hi i'm ria and these are my favorite
snacks
[Music]
i think japanese people take snacks very
seriously the biggest difference i
noticed is
we have seasonal snacks in spring we
have cherry blossom flavor
like fall we have chestnut flavor
pumpkin flavor so don't miss it when you
visit japan
look for those seasonal flavor because
you only have it in certain period of
time
i'm on the crush party
i feel like it's premium because um
there is only
seven in a package so you only get
14 of them and these are more expensive
than regular pockets when i was little i
had one dollar snack along once every
day and this is more than one dollar
and i couldn't eat this every day but
it's kind of special pocky
it's sure good
pumari meijin kinako mochi how can i
describe this this is if
cotton candy and rice cracker had a baby
this is
the baby
i'm having such a difficult time
bringing back from japan because this is
very delicate so you cannot put in a
suitcase or like backpack it will crush
into a powder i'm so happy that i can
eat it
in the steaks should i
hold it
so light
yeah it's immediately melting your mouth
this is koalas march it's quite unmatchy
in japanese
it has been around for a long time this
is basically a
cookie
shaped like koala and chocolate filling
inside so there is a koala has an
appendix surgery
so he had skull on his stomach and he's
crying but turns out if you find that
koala it's lucky
but i'm not sure if they are still doing
that it was the thing when i was
younger like in high school
is what was not lucky koala but
i want to see
other
eyebrow or authentic squala let's see
nope
turns and i'm not lucky today
i feel like it goes smaller
do you think it's got smaller or did i
get bigger i don't know
yeah it's like very nostalgic
very cute snacks
and this is
my favorite chocolate snack as of
2022
this is called kantorimam chopomamire
this is so good and i
brought it home and i tried to look for
it in
grocery store in here but i think this
is a little too new to sell in the u.s
so i am so happy
and thank you
this is a kind of 2.0 version of the
country mom
so this one um this one is original and
this has been around but
this is the
2.0 version i think so it's almost like
you have this like
melted chocolate and someone
accidentally dropped it
and realized this is more delicious than
the original one
when you eat it
it's like very soft chocolate chip
cookie and it's not too sweet
can i take this home
all right this one is pizza potato
it's um thick
potato chips and cheese bits
if can you see that like cheese
um oh yeah it's good
but we
do have a very different pizza culture
than
in the states and we do have very
different flavors like teriyaki chicken
and mayonnaise i think a lot of people
kind of like what but my own pizza is
very popular in japan i think it is like
very well engineered snack clothes and
potato chips has rich so
it
catches the cheese
that's kind of eating like pizza and
potato chips at the same time
[Music]
that's it and i'm maria and those are my
favorite snacks
check out my videos on tasty and about
to eat i also have my own youtube
channel real mark fellaini
[Music]